the las vegas mega rapper has a hits on
capitalizing on a new meme loza
alexander's let's go brandon is number
two on the itunes charts the popular
republican meme stems from a nascar
interview where a reporter thought the
crowd was saying let's go brandon which
was the name of a driver she was
interviewing what was actually being
said was blank joe biden loza alexander
turned it into a song and it basically
took off from there he says he wants the
song to give people a sense of freedom
people are in fear right now losing
their jobs and you know we got heroes
and and doctors and nurses people that
then took care of people last year with
the cove and they're getting rid of them
it's the most highest level of
disrespect
that i've ever seen and that's why a lot
of hip-hop artists are doing something
about it now it's almost hard to ignore
alexander says he became a trump fan
after talking to a friend around the 4th
of july he says he likes his policy the
song hit number one on the hip-hop chart
on itunes and has been sitting at number
two overall behind adele's newest hit
alexander says he is now working on a
full album